hello happy Halloween and welcome back
to bloodline the taxonomy of fear where
we break down what if anything makes a
movie scary I'm during crochet old and
I'm Jay beard and today we'll be looking
at the movie chain which stars Vincent
D'Onofrio as Bob the cab driving serial
killer who abducts a woman and her son
promptly kills the woman chains the Sun
down in his house and raises him as his
protege like name some rabbit yes and
this movie directed by Jennifer Lynch of
yes that Lynch Fame David Lynch's
daughter and true to form what you'd
expect she delivers a positively
Lynchian creepy experience in this
serial killer profile movie so what
defines a serial killer profile number
one obviously it's all about the killer
less about the victims I'm like
Halloween or slasher films where you
follow the victims along here you're
with the killer all the time you watch
them make breakfast you watched Maisie
sharpen some knives and it's also kind
of humanizing to the point where it's
uncomfortable yeah monster does a very
good job can you feel the sympathetic
for Shirley Stewart yes and with that
movie you got to stick with her the
whole time and you really got to see
everything she was going through and
with this movie what I got to see a
Vincent an offering on bob was great but
there was a lot of behind closed doors
action as far as the victim and oceans
the killings I would have liked to have
gone behind those doors and in addition
to the humanizing elements of his life I
would have liked to have seen the
vilifying elements of life in a bit more
clear I did not want to go behind those
closed tips you're a little bit darker I
am I just wanted a few more scares
number two number two an intense but
very performance by the lead character
is just so important like you said
oscar-winning turned by charlize theron
and monster Vincent D'Onofrio really
turns on a great performance here and
you need to be able to believe in that
humanity that you are given you need to
pick up you know you need to buy what
they are selling and I think he really
sells well good way of speaking he has
this weird lumbering block he's perfect
perfectly cast yeah he's excellent yes
where do you think that you are on the
food chain rabbit number three it
convincing backstory zero a killer
profiles need to have a convincing
enough traumatic and effects where it
can justify the character becoming
because we as audience members need to
be a little bit and Frank and believe
that despite everything people are still
good at heart because it's a little too
unsettling to believe otherwise yes and
I feel like the back story in this was
pretty damn he and then well while
heinous I do agree I I think there was
some incongruity between the domestic
violence that spurred the creation of
Bob as we come to know him in the movie
and the way he plays out this past pain
throughout the course of the film I way
to get thanked up that was okay with
that because it's a female director and
I was okay with her pushing the misogyny
so sure and I like the Baxter because I
felt it not only informed the character
it really tied an ending and to me
recast the whole movie yeah the
information that you receive it does put
the whole movie like you said a new
light and I think it does succeed there
even if I think the presentation of that
information is a little bit of ski did
feel like a little bit of a different
movie at the end and now it's time for
what we learned this week some horror
movie survival lessons Jay number one
brush up on your human anatomy knowing
where the basic organs are might help
save your life to know where maybe the
pancreas ping okay with a heart this
life is your life stick it right there
the room number to be aware of your
possible escape routes and like they
tell you on the airplane some of your
exits may be behind you those eyes open
if you really want to get out be aware
number three if someone is teen you down
whether that's literally or
metaphorically take a good look at those
shackles and they might not be as secure
as you think and you could be able to
get out faster than you thought yes
number four if there are two killers
there's always a week 10 in on that one
he's your way out you're she is your way
out you might be able to manipulate them
or maybe even seduce them for that kind
of person yeah use the tools you got in
your tool belt huh that's right and
number five do not fall victim to
Stockholm of sin
remember who you are who you care about
your name who you love before someone
else got it with your life what's your
name rabbit hours of sleep lost after
watching chained yes Jordan I didn't
really lose any it was I liked it a lot
but it was a character drama it was an
intense slasher movie I couldn't really
focus enough on one thing to be kept up
by it wow I lost two hours mostly
because I was really troubled by not
what you think is gonna be troubling in
the movie but me the paternal almost
tender moments between Bob and rabbit
like yeah and the candy bar he buys in
the chair to watch yeah you together I
felt oh that's really kind of sweet but
oh no I shouldn't feel feel like it's so
manipulative and of abused by them yeah
I do anything it is some Stockholm all
right serial killer profile movie
inspired video pic of the week J what do
you got I'm gonna go with David
Jacobson's Dahmer's came out in 2002
starring a young Jeremy Renner with such
intensity that you can easily see how he
goes on to be nami one from back to my
place okay excellent big Renner fan
mm-hmm and I'm gonna go with Tom T
covers perfume the story of a murderer
as sort of understated very artsy horror
film that came out in 2006 Alan Rickman
Dustin Hoffman and Tom t4 is actually a
director in the upcoming Cloud Atlas as
well with the Wachowskis so visionary
sort of guy implementing some
interesting elements to the dark
obsessions of a perfumer turn serial
killer alright that's it for this week's
episode of bloodline move back in a
couple weeks with something different
yes know yet but we don't know what that
is yet but it'll be different yeah we'll
just promise big things and hopefully
not fall short so an email if you have
any questions comments concerns at
bloodline at wired com let us know what
you think of our cat yes or our drunk
uncle yes and as we like to say here at
bud line remember it's just a movie come
on
you